so when ronnie was out in l.a last mimet
was out there too and that can give you
more details but uh ronnie was just
being a grumpy old man
no i wasn't i was high all right we took
him to a dispensary and he picked the
biggest blunt in the whole store and a
blunt if you don't know
that's like it's not a joint it's more
like a cigar like this big round thing
you put in your mouth all right here's
ronnie with his blunt
how much [ __ ] is it
10 milligrams you're gonna drink the
whole [ __ ] thing there's only ten
there's more than that go [ __ ] yourself
and yeah if you smoke the whole thing
i'm not smoking the whole thing
are you [ __ ] crazy
gee oh my god ronnie's smoking the only
strain of pot that makes you more angry
he came alive when he put on these skull
sunglasses he saw them in the sunglasses
store and it was like light came down
from the heavens he really enjoyed them
they were the greatest thing ever when
you were [ __ ] high with these all you
saw were the skulls man it was [ __ ]
cool wait that's ronnie's thing skull
yeah
i was like
scared the kids even more again you're
seeing like an angry man with skulls in
his eyes standing by the playground you
really walked around with that yeah yeah
we walked around the whole [ __ ] dead
man
it's cold skull sunglasses and my skull
depends
on the prescription put in those how
[ __ ] cool are these glasses i'm
curious to see what else he was wearing
i always find his uh his like uh dressed
down outfits very interesting let me
just describe what i'm looking at but
that is holding up a picture of ronnie
on the beach and he has his skull
glasses on and he's wearing a skull
t-shirt what does it say to the world
when you wear a skull i like skulls
no i don't know why why do you like that
no what i'm saying what is that they
look cool what are you trying to tell us
i think they look [ __ ] cool that's
all
mike you're laughing do you think it's
cool to have a skull on your shirt
i think he's he's going for something
there but he's that that's can i tell
you i've been wearing it hey [ __ ] i've
been doing that for [ __ ] years i'm
not going for anything i like can i tell
you my theory
i'll tell you my theory
you always have a theory doc ronnie's
worried he's going to be a skull stone
that's right that's what i was doing
meanwhile these two dudes have sexual
tension because
mike fox was telling me he thinks it's
clear that ronnie wants to [ __ ] mike
perlman
mike fox of all people to say that
you find mike attractive and to be
honest everybody mike's an executive guy
but we do well ronnie you're right cause
ronnie told john blitz that he would
[ __ ] mike perlman if he was gay because
uh john blitz said if you were gay would
you [ __ ] because you had mike
parliament dude you you got to hear up
the questions this guy comes up with he
he's insane
the question if i get the question you
had an answer
your answer's insane that's my that's my
job to answer him okay so if you were
gay you wouldn't [ __ ] mike crawman
no i would
why are we going well
why do you want to [ __ ] mike perlman if
you're gay like why not me or why why
mike i don't know i didn't know
it popped into my head here's a as a
reminder when ronnie was under hypnosis
remember he was a girl named angelina
yeah he wanted to [ __ ] mike permanent
and this is very intriguing i think here
we go who's the guy on the staff you
really want to [ __ ] tell me what you
do to him
you [ __ ] smoking hot
who is smoking hot
who is it
mike perlman mike perlman
just got shot he got shot he's right by
that yeah yeah
he's a bad boy you know look at julian
how are you doing
there he is
are you proud that ronnie like does it
make you feel
not good a little disturbing
does it make you feel funny about ronnie
you know it's like weird like i'll talk
to ronnie is like amazing like you know
we'll talk about something with cars or
something i'll ask him a question about
cars or whatever and then the back of my
head i'm thinking like you know this guy
wants to [ __ ] me
he's such an [ __ ]
the 426 hemi was a great car can i blow
you
you